public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
invité ce soir de l'épreuve de vérité
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
est républicain ici au sénat et le
président de la région les pays de la
loire
bonsoir bonsoir chers aux siens et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' agence france
presse avec les échos et radio classique
et vous répondrez à trois questions que
viendront vous posez jean-francis
pécresse mickaël szames s et es borrat
claude d'abord comment jugez-vous le
calendrier des mesures fiscales qui donc
va s'étirer en fait sur tout le
quinquennat puisque premier ministre l'a
dit à la france sur le plan budgétaire
est dans les cordes
deuxième question est ce que le scénar à
faire office de contre pouvoir emmanuel
macron et à son gouvernement
enfin comment la droite votre parti
doit-il se reconstruire entre attitude
constructive et critique est d'abord une
toute première question
[Musique]
1h15 de discours efficacité confiance
courage conquête ce sont les mots
fétiches du premier ministre aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il a réussi selon vous sur la
forme puisque on va entrer vraiment dans
le détail ensuite son grand oral
moi je les trouvais à l'attention
puisque c'était gérard collomb qui
prononçait le discours dont parle pas eu
nous au sénat en direct le premier
ministre mais encore une fois une heure
trente de discours c'est trop en deux
jours fait chez rml mâcon qui nous
affligent et un discours qui était très
très long
là à nouveau plus d'une heure plusieurs
ennemis de discours en tout cas au sénat
et l'origine est un peu plus lent alors
manifeste changer trop la bouche du
ministre de l'intérieur je trouvais en
tout cas que il y avait une distorsion
entre ces mots là le courage c'est à
dire une forme de volonté en marche si
j'ose dire et la route qu'on ne voyait
pas bien c'est à dire que on s'en tient
des objectifs parfois généraux mais on
voit pas comment on y parvient c'est le
cas par exemple de la dépense publique
mais j'imagine comment on va en parler
mais a quand même edouard philippe a
réussi à exister aujourd'hui on en avait
dit qu'il avait dissout phagocyté par le
président grand public non oui mais
c'est ce que je crois être un démenti à
tout ce qui a pu être dit ces derniers
jours
c'est ce que je ne comprends pas si le
positionnement du président de
république et du premier ministre
pourquoi parce que hier président
république c'est un peu enfermé dans son
propre piège en voulant s'exprimer avant
le premier ministre il sait condamnée à
être très générale trop général parfois
lyrique on aime on n'aime pas j'aime
bien inspiré intellectuellement
oui oui mais il ya certaines parties que
j'ai que j'ai apprécié franchement on
peut le faire mais une heure et demie
c'est très long trop général trop
générale sauf sur les institutions mais
très franchement ça n'est pas ce
qu'attendent les français proches des
verts à layher est aujourd'hui aux
journées à venir également non encore
assez général s'est dit qu'on attend du
premier ministre quand il dit par
exemple la france a une addiction à la
dépense publique ou en tout cas l'état
il va falloir nous désintoxiquer
on attend de savoir comment on va se
désintoxiquer on écoute et on a une
litanie de dépenses supplémentaires
que ce soit sur le fameux service
militaire d'un mois
qui va coûter notre commission des
finances de la défense les affaires
étrangères a mesuré le poids cette
charge financière ça sera 30 milliards
50 milliards donc d'investissement donc
il ya d'un côté la proclamation
d'objectifs mais de l'autre on ne voit
pas les moyens pour y parvenir en vert
reprend que ça dans le détail mais vous
le connaissez edouard philippe même s'il
n'a jamais des fillonistes parce qu'il
n'a jamais été fignolé connaissez ma
alors je connais vous avez aujourd'hui
j'ai donné dans tout d'abord c'était à
me la sarkozie juppé et cialis c'est du
passé c'est du passé et franchement j'ai
aussi des amis super puissance a choisi
de vous avez vu aujourd'hui en soi une
lettre de droite mais peu importe
en tout cas dans le discours il ya cette
volonté effectivement et et on sent
notamment à travers la dépense publique
on sent une volonté d'apurer les comptes
de l'autre quand même mais aussi des
annonces sur la fiscalité
décalé par contre la csg on va taper les
retraités tout de suite oui alors les
français qui roulent au diesel doivent
septembre trek le nom verge ans de la
fiscalité la convergence de la fiscalité
sur l'essence
moi je le traduis les français n'ont
peut-être pas compris ça veut dire que
quand vous allez faire un plein de 60
euros et faisant de 5 euros vous allez
en propre dont 10 ou 15 euros
supplémentaires alors je vous sens très
allants pour commenter les mesures
fiscales annoncées aujourd'hui sont le
premier ministre pas seulement elles
sont nombreux il y en a d'autres
il ya des mesures en matière d'éducation
de santé de fiscalité donc surtout pour
quand même on va en parler tout de suite
avec jean francis pécresse le directeur
de la rédaction de radio classique qui
nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir enfance et soir michel bonsoir
bruno retailleau alors on parlera
évidemment dans sa gérante mesures
fiscales qui ont été annoncées par
edouard philippe mais avant comment
est-ce que vous jugez ce calendrier
fiscal puisque plusieurs plusieurs
baisses d'impôts ont été différées sur
les prochaines années
tellement classique d'abord ce que je
veux dire c'est que il ya quand même un
class traçantes
il s'est assez classique classique voilà
pour utiliser un épithète vraiment ya un
contraste entre d'un côté le
réquisitoire qu'elle s'est livré le
premier ministre aujourd'hui le
président de la république hier
puisqu'il a qualifié les années hollande
d'immobilisme et aujourd'hui le
réquisitoire que le premier ministre a
fait c'était quoi c'était de dire que
c'était n'importe quoi sur le plan des
comptes c'est bon tout ces gens là ont
accompagné monsieur hollande quand même
monsieur collomb par exemple qui
prononçait le discours ici à voter tous
les têtes et les budgets bien
donc nous on connaissait puisque le
sénat on était beaucoup critiqué par
certains médias je me souvient mais moi
quand nous avions refusé parce que nous
le trouvions à ça sert de voter la
deuxième partie du budget donc première
chose le constat ils ne découvrent pas
ils font mine de le découvrir
ensuite alors je vous dis que c'est de
la cour des comptes entre temps quand je
vous disais que c'était clair non mais
leur rapport du sénat au dessus ya huit
mois
le principe absolument notre rapporteur
général albéric de montgolfier avait
fait ce constat
maintenant ce dont vous me parlez c'est
tellement usuels c'est à dire que on va
avoir le matraquage de la cg tout de
suite la fiscalité écologique très
rapidement en même temps pour les
français
et évidemment par exemple là où on est
très handicapée la fiscalité sur le
capital
la fameuse flat tax on va augmenter la
fiscalité sur le capital puisque
l'augmentation de la csg va se traduire
sur un alourdissement de la ressource
qui permet aux entreprises d'investir et
l'investissement de demain ou
d'aujourd'hui c'est toujours l'emploi de
demain ou après demain
donc si vous voulez de ce côté là il ya
une grande déception
et cette déception ne peut pas être mis
sur le contre qu'il ne savait pas où en
étais budgétairement il le savait et
d'ailleurs si vous
rectifiez vraiment cette trajectoire il
ferait un collectif budgétaire
ils ne le font pas ils citent au fond le
retour de la vieille politique c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de vous dire
c'est la politique à l'ancienne
je trouve que c'est la politique à
l'ancienne exactement ça a été le
réflexe de tant de gouvernements de
temps couvert mais différée quand même
certaines de certaines baisses d'impôts
comme la baisse de l'impôt sur la
fortune ou la transforma se veut dire
que ça sera vrai sens de monsieur en
baisse de charge des scoops voilà est-ce
que c'est raisonnable ou est ce que
c'est un enterrement en fait non si vous
voulez gelé le d'hier moi je pense j'ai
pris au mot le président de république
en citant les trois révolutions le mot
révolution est en réalité le titre du
livre qu'il a écrit pour sa campagne je
pense qu'on n'a pas de révolution on a
quelques réformes et la grande
révolution à faire c'est la révolution
économique
comment fait-on baisser le chômage de
masse bien sûr modifiant droit du
travail et on pourra l'accompagner mais
en baissant drastiquement le coût du
travail
et là encore il faudra attendre puisque
le cic ne se transformera demain en
baisse de charges sur les salaires cac
aux calendes grecques et c est donc je
ne vois pas les outils d'une baisse
importante en tout cas du chômage
en tout cas c'est baisser les chiffres
et par le premier ministre on va
l'écouter car ils l'expliquent du
chômage elop de la baisse de la pression
fiscale passe la fiscalité elle elle est
programmée et il donne le chiffre
d'abord rassurer nos concitoyens
les contribuables ne seront pas la
variable d'ajustement du budget les
prélèvements obligatoires baisseront de
20 milliards d'euros d'ici 2022
la france ne peut demeurer à la fois la
championne de la dépense publique est la
championne des impôts
votre réaction à cet argumentaire donc
du premier livre sur il dit donc un
point de pib d'ici 2022
il ya non mais encore une fois pour ne
pas systématiquement opposée encore une
fois je partage le constat la france est
à la fois double championne du monde
avec la finlande pour les dépenses
publiques et en même temps en europe
pour les prélèvements obligatoires donc
constat juste mais il dit ensuite on va
baisser obtenir
baisse relative je pense que c'est cela
par rapport au pib d'un point des
prélèvements obligatoires ça veut dire
que on va rien faire
ça veut dire que in attendent simplement
j'imagine que le pib augmente et que
mécaniquement si le pib augmente le
poids relatif par rapport aux impôts je
l'ait compris comme ça en tout cas va
finalement stagner ou baisser d'un point
pareil pour la dépense publique la
dépense publique vous dire là l'an
prochain nous serons nous atteindrons
avec la dette pratiquement 100 % de la
richesse nationale
c'est dramatique et on voit bien que ce
qui nous a proposé le premier ministre
c'est une augmentation de la dette
je peux pas les chiffres et je pense
qu'elle sera d'ici la fin du quinquennat
entre 250 milliards et 300 milliards
donc vous vous imaginez cette bombe
sociale qui risque d'éclater sous nos
pieds et est de mettre à mal je pense
que le modèle social français vous ne
parlez pas d'une mesure qui était prévu
il met beaucoup
non mais la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation oui ok reporter également
un oui à la fin du quinquennat laguna
qui s'est étalée là vous ne vérifiez pas
parce que finalement vous étiez contre
oui alors je vais vous dire pour des
majorités pas c'est que c'est
contradictoire puisque qu'est-ce qui
nous a dit il nous a dit les français
vont en bénéficier
très bien plus tôt et en même temps les
communes
il y aura pas de problème retrouveront
la ressource je comprends pas d'où va
venir à ce moment là la taxe
d'habitation
si la taxe d'habitation le produit de la
taxe d'habitation est compensée pour les
communes
à ce moment là c'est que l'impôt si
c'est pas un impôt local
il vient d'un impôt national ou d'une
ressource nationale
donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise d'autre mais finalement ce qui
a été de l'appréciation positive alors
non je pense que sur la taxe
d'habitation ce n'est pas clair du tout
comme beaucoup d'autres choses et il
faudra trancher ce que j'ai compris là
encore pour les français c'est qu'ils
devront attendre avant d'en bénéficier
mais je pense que ça atteint ce lien
citoyen parce que quand on est dans une
commune le fait d'avoir des services
publics ça coûte
et si demain tout est gratuit il y aura
un problème voilà donc votre jeu
merci beaucoup jean-francis deuxième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité maintenant
avec michaël szames est public sénat qui
nous rejoint
[Musique]
fabriqué à saint michel mont saint bruno
retailleau pour sam cassell je vais vous
parler un petit peu du sénat est ce
qu'il va faire maintenant office de
contre pouvoir quand on vous entend
depuis tout à l'heure
non c'est pas le rôle du sénat c'est pas
du tout le rôle du sénat
le sénat c'est une institution qui ne
procède pas de l'élection présidentielle
je me faire comprendre
il ya un déséquilibre depuis le
changement de calendrier désormais les
élections législatives ont lieu dans la
foulée des élections présidentielles et
donc elles ne sont qu'une réplique
sismique donc on a une assemblée
nationale on le voit bien qui est un
wagon accrocher le wagon législatif de
l'assemblée nationale accrochez de très
près à la locomotive de l'exécutif mais
la démocratie c'est pas seulement
suffrage universel la démocratie c'est
aussi la séparation des pouvoirs est
donc cette séparation des pouvoirs est
incarnée aujourd'hui par notre
institution
le sénat qui est à l'écart de ses
mouvements si aujourd'hui elle du cycle
présidentiel donc on s'est muée
l'assemblée ce n'est plus la séparation
des pogos non non pourquoi parce que il
ya ce qu'on appelle le fait majoritaire
qui est renforcée par le quinquennat et
l'inversion de l'agenda est aujourd'hui
cette séparation est mieux assumée par
le sénat donc vous poser une question
contre-pouvoir ou pas je dis non le
sénat doit rester la tête froide
avec un peu de hauteur de distance et a
porté sur chaque texte une amélioration
parce que les textes qui vous viennent
souvent de l'assemblée sans parfois des
brouillons pas toujours mais parfois des
brouillons on a nous un rôle
améliorateur royaume de la loi et
ensuite on cherchera pas à s'opposer
pour s'opposer mais vous n'en saurez
quoi dans une forme d'opposition
constructive comme le dit gérard dans
une opposition intelligente on sera bien
sûr une opposition intelligente mais
vigilante
parce que depuis depuis finalement
l'élection de l'après du président de la
république
c'est tout juste si on doit pas
s'excuser d'être dans l'opposition mais
là encore qu'est ce que c'est que la
démocratie c'est quand même l'existence
d'une opposition pour la possibilité
demain d'une alternance on doit pas
laisser le monopole de l'opposition
aux deux extrêmes extrême droite extrême
gauche est-ce que vous
imaginez peut-être que en marche puisse
faire son entrée au sénat
et quelles seraient les répercussions
pour vous parce que ça peut aussi
peut-être faire changer déjà fait
courant s'est déjà fait la grèce via un
groupe en marche mais le groupe en
marche
en réalité au sénat c'est un
démembrement du groupe du parti
socialiste ce ne sont que des gens venus
du parti socialiste c'est à 99.9 pour
vous ne craignez pas d'hémorragie
aujourd'hui je vais vous pousse plus
loin qu'il va y avoir ensuite il va
ailleurs des élections sénatoriales
c'est septembre ça arrive toujours être
humble et toujours là être prudent quand
il ya une élection au suffrage universel
indirect aussi et donc on verra bien
j'avais ma réunion de groupe ce matin je
pense que il ya une cohérence et ya une
cohésion entre nous qui fait que au jour
d'aujourd'hui on n'a pas connu ici au
sénat les soubresauts de l'assemblée
nationale tentation macron chez vous il
n'y a pas de tentation macron pour le
moment mais il faudra attendre aussi
l'élection recettes mais ce que j'espère
voyez c'est que on n'est pas une
hégémonie
on voit bien que l'assemblée nationale
il ya une tentation hégémonique avec ce
qui s'est passé la semaine dernière sur
la questure etc
c'est du jamais vu d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire de l'assemblée nationale il
ya une tentation hégémonique au niveau
des exécutifs puisqu'il va y avoir le
spot système c'est pas le spoil system
le président de république va remplacer
250 à 300 haut fonctionnaire pour avoir
des gens des femmes et hommes à sa main
très bien bon il faudrait pas que le
sénat soit demain aussi à la botte pour
marcher au pas donc moi je veux bien
marché dans ce sens de l'intérêt général
mais certainement pas marché à propos
des sénatoriales ont dit que jean paul
delevoye est déjà très actif ici pour
organiser un peu le scrutin indirect
vous l'avez dit
vous inquiète est ce qu'il ya des
manoeuvres en cours non non je n'ai
aucune inquiétude concernant jean paul
delevoye
ce sont les électeurs les grands
désigner des candidats magron
compatibles bah écoute et qui fait pour
venir de votre camp la recomposition est
en marche au sénat qu'il fasse qu'il
fasse son casting très bien mais je
doute que les grands électeurs
apprécient a la même valeur si j'ose
dire les candidats internet comme
certains députés ont pu l'être je pense
que vis-à-vis des grandes idées
convergent ce gros lecteurs en tout cas
et on juge sur pièce je veux dire que
les grands électeurs ne se font pas
intimider par une étiquette beaucoup
beaucoup moins beaucoup beaucoup moins
que pour les élections législatives et
qui sont négatifs on l'a bien vu
il y avait plein de candidats qui était
totalement inconnu mais c'était leur
sens où vous avez la cause leur mairie
tous les qualifiés de candidats internes
est pas du tout simplement
j'observe que il avait besoin sur leurs
affiches de faire figurer la photo des
manèges macron pas comme si il était élu
par procuration eh bien je pense que ce
simplement ce que je vous dis c'est que
les grands électeurs sont souvent très
exigeant sur la personnalité l'ancrage
l'enracinement ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il
n'a pas fait mais de toute façon c'est
toujours le suffrage universel qui est
le seul juge
voilà il faut l'accepter alors vous
allez exercer vous l'avez dit une
opposition vigilante notamment sur les
questions fiscales on les a abordés il
ya également le big bang institutionnel
qui est annoncé par emmanuel macron hier
au congrès michael je vais commencer
dans l'aude mais on va d'abord parlé de
la proportionnelle qu'est ce que vous
attendez de savoir à partir de quelle
dose
on va instaurer cette conventionnelles
pour en mesurer les conséquences
non moi je pense que la proportionnelle
en réalité c'est une fausse bonne idée
c'est une fausse bonne idée parce que ça
peut conduire à des assemblées
nationales absolument sans majorité
et à chaque fois qu'on a vu sous la
quatrième république
les assemblées nationales chambre des
députés sur la troisième qui n'avait pas
suffisamment de cohérence à chaque fois
il ya eu un problème pour la france
le gouverneur de représentativité c'est
peut-être aussi ce que les françaises
souhaitent ces thèmes que je pense que
je relance aussi oui alors le problème
avec les modes de scrutin c'est que l'on
un scrutin majoritaire il est efficace
il va donner une majorité au
gouvernement pour gouverner pour
réformer la france et la proportionnelle
effectivement on va vers beaucoup plus
de représentativité le problème c'est
que la france est terriblement des
visées
et si demain vous aviez une assemblée
nationale finalement à l'image de ce qui
a été le premier tour des
présidentielles où on avait finalement
quatre blocs sans compter une grande
part de français qu'ils soient s'étaient
abstenus ou avaient voté de façon très
très divers sur des extrêmes
eh bien vous auriez assemblée nationale
très fracturée j'ajoute que cumuler la
proportionnelle avec le non cumul des
mandats vous obtiendrez des députés vous
obtiendrez des députés totalement hors
sol ils seront même plus enraciné dans
une circonscription puisque on aura des
listes nationales présentées par les
partis donc ça c'est vraiment la toute
puissance des partis qui positionnons
sur des listes investi par leurs soins
qui positionne ont leur candidat vous
êtes entendu dire que la
représentativité c'est l'instabilité
je pense que il faut se méfier et que
l'élection majoritaire permet à la fois
de choisir les français ou les indiens
c'est ce que vous nous dites ce soir
jeudi que trop de proportionnelle c'est
dangereux a redoré évidemment il ya
aussi la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
est ce que le sénat que vous représentez
par la force d'opposition votre à ce
texte comme l'a demandé le chef de
l'état hier je pense que sur la
réduction des parlementaires on peut
tout à fait aller dans le sens de cette
mesure
le candidat que j'ai soutenu avait fait
cette proposition
pendant l'élection présidentielle là
aussi c'est un package tout est une
question ah bah non non nous faut pas
nous dire c'est non non ça ne marche pas
comme ça c'est pas prendre ou à laisser
on a un droit d'amendement petit peu ce
que on a un droit d'amendement et
m'accroupir ah oui mais donnons sa
nounou non mais c'est pour çà d'elvis et
moi je nomme mais moi je ne suis pas si
le petit doigt sur la couture du
pantalon pour répondre au sourire que
nous adressent au maquereau en fait
c'est pas c'est pas le problème mon
problème à moi c'est la france et
l'intérêt des français je m'explique
là encore bien sûr je suis d'accord mais
il arrive un seuil par exemple sur les
sénateurs ou les territoires qui sont
pauvres en démographie c'est à dire les
territoires ruraux
la france périphérique ne serait plus
représenté donc il faut calculer le
seuil qui permet notamment au sénat mais
aussi pour les députés
voir quand même au moins un sénateur un
représentant parce que au-delà d'un
seuil
vous avez plus de représentation des
territoires pour la france il verra que
les grandes métropoles mondialisée c'est
en même temps des territoires c'est la
spécificité française par rapport
d'ailleurs à nos partenaires européens
merci mais quel est le troisième partie
de l'épreuve de vérité bruno retailleau
maintenant avec deborah claude notre
consoeur de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint pour sa question
les proches des victimes avec l'eye fi
bonsoir deborah mont saint michel mont
soir bruno retailleau bonne question
alors vous êtes un des artisans de la
défaite de la droite française si vous
étiez excusez moi c'est un peu dur mais
à proche de françois fillon
lavaud prête beaucoup de pouvoir fonder
comment vous allez
dans votre famille politique refonder la
droite française comment vous
l'envisagez moi d'abord à un mot vous
dit vous êtes un des artisans je vous
dire bien sûr moi j'ai vécu cette
campagne présidentielle façon
douloureuse
j'étais un de ceux qui ont constaté
qu'il n'y avait pas de plan d parce
qu'il y avait des rivalités moi et que
je suis pas de ceux qui quittent le
navire au milieu de la tempête
je pense que la loyauté et la fidélité
la fidélité
maintenant je pense que sans doute la
responsabilité dans le sac contient un
échec il faut jamais le rejeter a priori
sur d'autres je suis parfaitement
d'accord sur cette analyse là simplement
la refondation de ma famille politique
je pense que elle passe d'abord par la
refondation des idées par leur fondation
en même temps d'un parti notre parti il
a toujours été très parisiens finalement
très centralisé et très personnalisé
c'est le culte du chef
bah ça c'est là à droite mais je pense
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui il nous faut
d'abord nous redéfinir quel idéal
voulons-nous porter général de gaulle
mails mâcon d'ailleurs a parlé à
plusieurs reprises d'humour réalité bien
sûr mais le général de gaulle avait une
phrase qui était plus belle encore
lisait la politique c'est l'action au
service d'un idéal à travers des
réalités quel idéal la droite française
quel idéal la droite française peut-elle
porter
comment est ce qu'on peut se définir il
faut bien sûr des débats simplement moi
je suis partisan est ce que votre chat
elle même que celui de laurent wauquiez
je vais vous dire je suis partisan de
repère les crève en début d'année en
début d'année d'enjamber la fin de
l'année de repousser l'élection du
président de celui qui devra pour
décembre inquiète est prévue pour la fin
de l'année
tout simplement parce que je sais
parfaitement que si on part tout de
suite sur la querelle des ego chacun
voudra se distinguer par rapport à
l'autre ce sera encore une fois des
plaies qui vont se réouvrir sur des
plaies qui ne sont pas refermées on a
fait cette erreur en 2012
moi ce que je propose c'est que on pose
le jeu on essaie de débattre on essaie
d'aller dans toutes les fédérations dans
les départements pour dire à nos
sympathisants pour dire à nos militants
qu'est ce que vous voulez nous quelle
est la ligne qui nous caractérise le
mieux
en face un travail de réorganisation sur
le fond et en même temps sur les idées
et ensuite dans un deuxième temps
j'ajoute on pourra procéder à une
élection
est-ce qu'on est à quelques mois près
j'ajoute qu'il va y avoir des avis
formulés absolument rien je l'ait déjà
formulé gelé déjà formulées et elle est
ce que je redoute autres membres bien
sûr absolument
mais ce que je redoute le plus c'est
qu'en plus en même temps l'élection
sénatoriale soit prise en otage
évidemment puisque les élections
sénatoriales ça sera au moins de
septembre hu à moi mon compte
prix 3 mois vent simplement les
procédures et les ego partiront bien
avant évidemment s'il ya une élection à
l'automne ou au mois de décembre
vous verrez très très rapidement il ya
eu des défections puisqu'on à xavier
bertrand qui a instauré ce ne serait pas
candidat n'a pas tourné qu'on ne les ait
pas l'urgence pour moi c'est pas de
l'urgence on a quelques années sans
élection on peut très bien au mois de
février par exemple élire un nouveau
président et essayer avant de travailler
au fond parce que nos militants on les
prend si j'ose dire pour des machines à
voter les français en ont marre de
toutes ces élections nos militants ça
fait depuis des mois et des mois avec
les primaires qu'on est dans des
séquences où on doit départager les uns
par rapport aux autres
peut-être qu'on peut peut-être un moment
un moment leur poser la question qu'est
ce que vous voulez que soit votre parti
à la tête de forces républicaines le
parti de françois fillon
qu'il y aura à la rentrée la tête de ce
parti pour l'instant on a une assemblée
générale qui était purement technique on
à l'été pour réfléchir et ce sera à la
rentrée au mois d'octobre j'imagine que
lui-même et pas non mais le il souhaite
se retirer
d'accord on souhaite même se retirer de
la ville a lancé oui oui quand est ce
que vous l'avez vu vous la dernière fois
ça fait plusieurs semaines mais je lis
au téléphone récemment mais je n'ai pas
vu depuis plusieurs semaines quand vous
vous parlez c'est pour commenter
l'actualité politique est là pas votre
parti à la fois les premières semaines
du gouvernement macron peu peu en
commande peu je pense que pour lui il
n'est pas dans le commentaire je pense
qu'il a souhaité tourner une page
c'était extrêmement douloureuse et quand
j'entendais le président de république à
versailles au congrès à dire que la
présomption d'innocence est quelque
chose d'important
je voudrais y compris pour mes propres
amis qui considère que la présomption
d'innocence c'est quelque chose de
fondamental
le couturier que françois fillon est en
reconstruction personnelle
bien sûr oui absolument bien sûr c'est
tellement violent j'ai tellement violent
ça l'affecté lui sa fac tu es sa famille
donc je n'en dirai pas plus mais quel
homme ne serait pas touché profondément
par un tel déchaînement de violence
souhaitent s'orienter vers le privé à un
prix mais c'est ce qui laisse son décès
c'est à lui de le dire c'est pas à moi
de les commenter
il ya une reconstruction qui est
compliqué qui est difficile ils
redoutent les prochaines étapes
judiciaires donc bah écoutez il y en a
eu certaines pour des enfants qui se
sont conclues plutôt positivement voilà
assez peu de choses qui ont filtré des
auditions
non c'est très bien et c'est trés
rappelant simplement simplement campagne
vous savez moi j'ai pu être le témoin de
ce déchaînement médiatique et judiciaire
est gelée comparé à ce que je vis ce que
j'ai observé depuis il ya un quart du
gouvernement les premiers gouvernements
des mailles macron qui n'a pas été
reconduit à cause des affaires ils sont
à l'assemblée maintenant au président et
si certains de mes amis qui ont ils dans
tellement dure vis-à-vis de françois
fillon avait eu la même dans dur pour
des affaires similaires mais eux
est-ce que je commentaire c'est une
observation
ça c'est vous vous reprocher à certains
votes ancien allié politique donc
d'avoir quitté la campagne à la fin
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils s'étaient
perdus ou est-ce qu'on vous reproche je
retape a été fidèle jusqu'au bout est ce
que vous le payez dans votre camp je
reproche rien à personne parce que la
violence a été telle
si vous voulez que je comprends les
attitudes des uns des autres ce que je
comprends pas c'est ceux qui ont une
dent dure quand il s'agit d'un tel et
une dans mol quand il s'agit d'un autre
voilà donc moi je n'accuse personne est
du reste je trouve que vis-à-vis de moi
les uns les autres et y compris
d'ailleurs dans mon groupe ont compris à
la loyauté et la fidélité
c'était des valeurs finalement dans la
vie mais c'était peut-être aussi des
valeurs en politique
voilà mais je pense encore une fois
juste souvent l'occasion m'en expliquer
que on a traversé un moment difficile il
faut se remettre
il faut se redresser c'est par le débat
c'est marc le respect la bienveillance
qu'on doit à chacun d'eux avec
éventuellement un ou très rapidement
bien vu vous vous épauler mutuellement
peut-être alors avec françois fillon
non vous échanges
c'était une façon de s'épauler n'y a pas
de théâtre non non non non non non non
mais non je n'ai pas vu depuis plusieurs
semaines et bien sûr gelé au téléphone
il ya quelques jours
première vue une question sans pas leur
rapport à l'argent et le magot de forces
républicaines parce que c'est vrai que
là alors volé l'argent de force mais
elle est revenue beaucoup sur et les
dons et l'argent de la primaire s'est
tordu demande instamment
de donner cet argent alors et donc
puisqu'il emmène moi je suis totalement
en millions d'euros
je suis totalement derrière la
proposition qu'a fait bernard acoyer de
nommer il a demandé à gilles carez qui
est un homme au dessus de tout soupçon
qui avait présidé la commission des
finances de lui mettre un rapport et ce
rapport ce sera un petit peu le juge de
paix d'accord ce sera un arbitre et je
pense qu'il faut pas qu on est entre
nous de discussion d'argent d'histoire
vergeur il faut il faut objectiver les
choses et très concret et aucun jeu je
veux moi plaidé dans ce sens là on
attend dans la jura tu rapportes merci
beaucoup d'avoir merci honoré période
avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]
là